I'm calling this the lightning round it
would be great if you guys cooperated
I'm not a potted plan here um and I want
to ask you we all know that federal
policy does have a huge impact on States
we know that I'm going to ask you three
simple questions and I just want
one-word answers okay from three of you
because our best we're coming up on a
break and the issue is right now Joe
Biden is President so uh I would like
both of you to give a grade to Joe Biden
overall as president governor new I'll
give a an a absolutely Master failed and
a failure okay that's your now number
two are his policies helping or hurting
your individual states is it helping the
State of Florida the inflation is
hurting our state big time great uh fail
he failed he's failed on the econom guy
just took million from the science in in
Tech ACT thank you Joe Biden uh it's
absolutely accelerating our dominance in
manufacturing accelerating our
revitalization a simple answer
unequivocally absolutely yes okay I will
ask you Governor DeSantis um I have
played over and over again and Governor
Nome you have seen over and over again
um Joe Biden is experienced what I
believe to be significant cognitive
decline and in other words it's the
toughest job in the world is Joe Biden
experiencing this cognitive decline is
it a danger to the country do you find
he speaks what is your reaction to it
yes he's in Decline yes it's a danger to
the country he has no business running
for president and you know Gavin Newsome
agrees with that he won't say that
that's why he's running his shadow
campaign uh he should not be running uh
he is not up to the job uh and it is
dangerous for this country well I'll
take I I will take Joe Biden at a 100
versus Ronda santis any day of the week
at any age in fact all of the fol you
think he's up to the job you think he's
100% time with in private you don't know
and by the way results matter inflation
now is down to 3.2% wages are up to 4.4%
the economy is booming 5.2% GDP growth
in the last quarter there's are facts
you don't hear on Fox News 14 million
jobs 10 times let me move on that was
the lightning round now on March 31st
1968 hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interview and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else